wo was oder wer ist in ihren Augen die
größte Gefahr für Deutschland
die größte Gefahr für unseren Frieden
und unsere Freiheit in Europa ist
traurigerweise seit dem 24 februar im
vergangenen Jahr diese russische
Regierung das russische Regime und daher
haben wir auch im Rahmen unser
nationalen Sicherheitsstrategie Dinge
anders formuliert zum Beispiel das Wort
Wehrhaftigkeit hätte ich wahrscheinlich
früher selber so nie in den Mund
genommen aber ja wir müssen als Europa
für unseren Frieden und unsere Freiheit
sorgen können und deswegen unterstützen
wir ja auch die Ukraine als europäischen
Partner in unserem gemeinsamen Europa
die Umsetzung dieser Strategie kostet
natürlich auch Geld insbesondere dass
erfüllen der nato-vorgabe zwei Prozent
der Wirtschaftsleistungen sollen ja in
die Verteidigung investiert werden ab
kommenden Jahr sogar das hat heute
Christian Lindner gesagt woher kommt
denn eigentlich das ganze Geld wenn das
Sondervermögen was er im Grunde auch
Schulden sind aufgebraucht ist
der Sondervermögen stellt erstmal dieses
Geld für jetzt bereit weil wir müssen
jetzt dringend neue Anschaffungen machen
nicht nur weil wir die Ukraine bei ihrem
Recht auf selbst Verteidigung und
Freiheit und Frieden unterstützen mit
bekanntermaßen zum Beispiel auch Panzern
die wir dann natürlich selber für uns
wieder neue modernisiert beschaffen
müssen sondern wir haben auch in den
letzten Jahren immer wieder erlebt gab
ja auch solche Schlagzeilen das
Hubschrauber nicht wirklich fliegen dass
das Material total veraltet ist und
deswegen müssen wir auch da wieder nicht
weil wir es wollen aber weil wir dazu
gezwungen sind mehr Geld in die Hand
nehmen für die Modernisierung der
Bundeswehr und hier aber das Gute im
Licht dieses Krieges haben wir erlebt
wie Unsinn ist ist sehr um mich zu sagen
falsch dass alle europäischen Partner
sich selber ihre eigenen panzersysteme
oder
Abwehrsysteme beschaffen und die da
nicht miteinander funktionieren und das
ist bei uns in der nationalen
Sicherheitsstrategie angelegt genauso
wie in dem überarbeiteten Konzept der
NATO und der EU das zukünftige
Beschaffung in Europa gemeinsam
kompatibel sein müssen das spart dann
für uns als gesamt Europa auch wieder
Geld damit wir nicht alles
aber Sie können ja nur sparen wenn sie
vorher auch irgendwo vielleicht schon
mal gehabt Geld locker gemacht haben
also noch mal die Frage woher kommt denn
das ganze Geld weil sie können nur
sparen wenn sie auch Geld haben
das stimmt und deswegen der
Sondervermögen hatten sie hier gerade
angesprochen das ist ein Teil der auf
Kredite finanziert wird und ein anderer
Teil wird aus dem Haushalt kommen das
ist eben leider auch die brutale
Realität das durch den russischen
Angriffs Krieg der russische Präsident
auch uns gezwungen hat in unserer eigene
Wehrhaftigkeit zu investieren stärker
als wir das bisher getan haben weil wir
darauf vertraut haben dass wir in Europa
gemeinsam immer in Frieden leben können
und das bedeutet jetzt zum Beispiel mit
Blick auf die Stärkung der Bundeswehr
dass wir bei diesem Haushalt deutlich
machen bei der Bundeswehr können wir
nicht kürzen sondern wir müssen dafür
sorgen dass wir die Ukraine weiterhin
militärisch unterstützen können und dass
wir selber für unsere eigene Sicherheit
als Bundesrepublik Deutschland in
unserem vereinten Europa sorgen können
sie wollten an anderen Stelle die
Verteidigungsausgaben koppeln und zwar
an die Entwicklungsausgaben das wird es
auch nicht geben warum nicht
zu Zeiten wo wir mit Russland den
Frieden gelebt haben mussten wir nicht
so intensiv in unserer eigene
Verteidigungsfähigkeit investieren
deswegen haben wir da deutlich gemacht
ist die Kooperation gerade im
Zusammenhalt der
Entwicklungszusammenarbeit in dem
Diplomatie humanitäre Hilfe können wir
der mehr Geld leisten jetzt sagen wir
nicht wir kürzen hier aber wir machen
deutlich dass wir auch in unsere
Verteidigungsfähigkeit investieren
müssen und solche Abwehrsysteme das ist
jetzt ja allseits bekannte wie viel
Milliarden so eine moderne
Luftverteidigung kostet das sind eben
ganz andere Dimension da wir so viel
jetzt aber über Militär sprechen sie ja
die Fragen auch dazu stellen das
Besondere an dieser nationalen
Sicherheitsstrategie ist dass wir zum
ersten Mal sagen früher hat das
Verteidigungsministerium ist
Außenministerium eine
Sicherheitsstrategie geschrieben
Sicherheit ist mehr als Militär und
Diplomatie es geht ja auch um
cybersicherheit es geht hier um
gesundheitssicherheit um das
Lebensmittelsicherheit das haben wir
alle bei Corona erlebt wenn wir
Antibiotika in Deutschland jemand nicht
mehr von anderen Teilen der Welt
bekommen können bei uns ist aber nicht
hergestellt wird auch das ist ein
Sicherheitsproblem und das ist eben
dieser integrierte ganzheitliche Ansatz
möglicherweise werden wir das ein oder
andere nicht mehr bekommen weil unser
Verhältnis zu China sagen wir mal
angespannt ist im Papier steht dazu das
Land versucht regelbasierte Ordnung
umzugestalten setzt seine
Wirtschaftsmacht im Grunde ein die
internationale Sicherheit damit auch
unter Druck ist also systemischer Rivale
bleibt aber Partner das ist alles sehr
abwägend und keine klare Haltung
also abwägend ist für mich nicht das
Gegenteil von klarer Haltung sondern es
beschreibt eben in einer Welt in dem wir
auf der einen Seite erleben dass
Autokratien Diktaturen auch in
systemwettbewerb also in den Gegensatz
zu Demokratien gehen dass wir da nicht
naiv sein dürfen das ist ja die bittere
Lehre aus unserer russland-beziehung in
der Vergangenheit da war das Prinzip
Hoffnung wir machen nur ganz viel
wirtschaftsbeziehung und dann werden wir
schon in Frieden leben das mussten wir
alle gemeinsam erst recht die Ukraine
bitter bezahlen diesen Fehler wollen wir
nicht noch mal machen und deswegen sagen
wir gegenüber China die sich in den
letzten Jahren auch massiv verändert
haben und eben diese beschrieben haben
unsere regelbasierte internationale
Ordnung nicht nur hinterfragen sondern
herausfordern machen wir deutlich wir
können uns nicht so abhängig machen wie
zuvor von Russland wir müssen uns
diversifizieren wir müssen uns breiter
aufstellen und zugleich so ist das in
einer globalisierten aber vor allen
Dingen vernetzten Welt wo CO2 nicht an
Grenzen Halt macht können wir die
Klimakrise nur in den Griff bekommen
wenn eins der größten Länder dieser Welt
nicht nur bevölkerungstechnisch sondern
auch mit einem starken Markt sich an
diesen Klima Vereinbarung beteiligt und
deswegen ja müssen wir alles dafür tun
dass wir mit China bei den Klima Fragen
die erdbeerwärmung auf unter zwei Grad
möglichst 1,5 Grad bringen